hey guys how's it going got this great
shirt on today because today I wanted to
chat with you guys about the Instagram
stories now before I get into really how
I feel I want to know how you guys feel
leave me some comments and let me know
why you'll be using snapchat over
Instagram stories or while you'll be
using his dream stories over snapchat
when you decide to make a piece of
content which one are you gonna choose
and why and for those of you who have no
idea what I'm talking about let me show
you how it works
so now when you open up Instagram you're
presented with a feed that looks like
this so up here at the top you'll see
here's my story so when I click it
you're able to view your story so when
you want to watch other people's stories
you just click on their little icon
there and you're able to see them to go
to the next one you just swipe over
swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe and if you
want to keep going on someone snapchat
Instagram story you just click it takes
you to the next one something that I
think that we're very familiar with
swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe down
to get rid of it post your Instagram
story you hit that little plus button up
there this is what you guys look like
filming filming oh my goodness some sort
of crazy inception they've also got
sponsors swipe over so we're going to
use this one one of the things that I
like the most about the Instagram
stories is this little not even sure but
to call it a glowing text feature and my
sister and Francesca are chatting
shoot and we're gonna post it we're able
to tell that somebody has a new post
five a little loop colored ring around
their icon so you can also add text much
the same as snapchat I do like this text
a little bit more than snapchat because
they added a slight little drop shadow
to it so if you put this over top of
something white you're able to actually
still read the text they also have
different types of pen styles so you can
write like that and also make it bigger
that's ugly so we're going to delete
that they've also got this one it's kind
of like a highlighter paint stroke thing
which I've seen a lot of people ruin too
city is turned down a little bit as well
so it's looking good the drawing
features in Instagram stories much
better if you happen to go through
something and you decide that you want
to post it to your Instagram feed you
just hit that little button right there
and you can do share his post and it'll
just open us right up and you can just
share it crop it hit next post but
that's hideous and I'm not hosting
that's my feed so here's my thoughts on
Instagram stories I actually really
really like it and I really really like
it because it's pretty much exactly like
snapchat I love snapchat I love so many
things about it and basically Instagram
kind of took all the good things a
snapchat and now moved it over to their
platform which is kind of ironic because
a few years ago Facebook tried to buy
snapchat for a lot of freaking money and
they're like nope so here we are not too
much longer later and now Instagram has
added this insane snap chat feature to
preface this I have been on Instagram
for a really long time I once found this
website where I'll tell you what user
number you are I'm pretty sure I was
like 103 or 108 person to ever join
Instagram so if we're talking about
old-school fangirling I am number one
Instagram fan right here maybe like 100
in 3rd but you get the point this is
where I think that Instagram had this
huge opportunity to make something that
was a little bit more revolutionary but
then you think about it snapchat is
already so perfect how do you perfect
something that is already so good so
many people are using but there's a lot
of people who aren't using it who are
using Instagram so why not make it
simple do the same exact thing in one
place and just make everyone sort of
happy except for the people who work at
snapchat all I know is I'm going to be
using both I don't really care I think
that both platforms have a huge
opportunity to do something a little bit
different I'm extremely excited to see
what Instagram does with these stories
my only real wish is that they would
have named it something a little bit
different perhaps something sort of
camera ish like
I'm not sure something along the theme
of an Instagram I mag um and I don't
know I guess if I did know but I'd
probably be working at insa room right
now or they could have taken their
previous platform of boomerang and kind
of integrated that into the stories and
made that its own thing but in the same
app I'm not sure just thinking out loud
here well I've also made this video to
show people who don't know how to use it
yet how to use it and I want to get your
feedback on your thoughts you want to
follow me on Instagram
my username is iJustine and snapchat
also iJustine that's it I'll see you
guys in the next video hope to see you
guys on snapchat and on Instagram it
potentially be the best invention ever
what'd you think of it